okay let's try what not to mouse lu9
have six work this time these six NIMS
oh I'm Sol and C - C - all right let's
strike at the pond that is unprotected
as a result of that last month I don't
like facing this what move are we on
what more are we on this is really deep
yeah this is deep stuff right here move
five what a thinker see what happens
when you don't pick up a chess book
openings 101 where are you okay we're
gonna have a three this is this is what
I've been thinking about I've been
giggling here it's sooner questions
gonna be thrown a bishop it's basically
saying usually take my night I go here
and I expand you get kicked around
let's develop a knight he's not going
anywhere just yet
why don't we do here what do we do I
think I should just von take here
without being provoked
yeah let's do this now maybe I want to
play night here oh okay I'm not like in
my position at all at all at all at all
I think I should have castled or
something instead of playing c5 I'm
already regretting certain things that
I've played and mmm
I feel like D fight like it's so simple
now for ye three I'm just gonna have
this guy being a liability so what a bug
what a bug what a bug so how can I be a
bug back to my opponent I'm gonna be a
little wreck I'm gonna just try to break
something
open here or could I do this move I just
play here now it's castle let's see what
that light square Bishop wants to do
first the plays here I'll be happier
you know why goes to d3 I know after
where I can maybe play d4 not worried
about rook d1 now what okay well maybe I
should do this maybe I shouldn't the
good stuff right here that's some great
line to use right there maybe I should
do this or maybe I shouldn't say that a
lot of situations can't you a five oh
man what do I do by my light square
bishop what a dummy what a dummy all
right I don't want to get pushed around
so 85 says no before no don't you dare I
gotta watch out for this because there's
tricks against it with the Queen
indirectly putting pressure on there and
I'm not comfortable at all in this
position
are you comfortable watching me in this
position
ah what a bug this is too easy this is
way too easy for my opponent right here
I might have to do this I'm gonna get
killed though pawn push Knight here just
drop a pawn for nothing let's just go
here no no no no no no I do not feel
good at all about this this is a
terrible terrible configuration look at
this dummy he should be thrown off the
board ah I hate my LightSquared Bishop I
hate them I got to take that and my dark
square Bishop getting hit oh this is a
killer I'm losing the exchange oh no I'm
not
Bishop here I could go here oh can you
tell this is my I wanna cry voice yepper
yes it is you take me I take you I'll be
okay with that I think my opponent gonna
go here and kill me oh no that's even
better that's even better
alright I'm officially down the exchange
and it gets even worse man
and oh man oh man oh man oh man I'm dead
I'm dead you know what time it is hello
time burners that's all I have ever
that's all I ever have time burners
learn how to play chess quit it with
your time burners that's all you ever do
that is all you ever do you and your
time burners I'm not even threatening to
take the night you realize that I guess
I'm getting ready to get these guys one
day my bishop is still an idiot by the
way he's still a fool and now this pawn
is getting beat up here I got take that
I think I don't want to but I think I
have to this pawn is gonna fall let's
just take there let's just take there
and rely upon a tricky Knight without
him I definitely have nothing less than
a minute ah man this is so bad why is
this so bad ah my opponent is having
none of my tricks now the bishop just
backs up it's as simple as that isn't it
or does that move right there
ah what a bug what a bug leave me alone
leave me alone I need to defend these
are wonderful moves that I'm making
right here if you didn't realize these
are wonderful moves wonderful oh it's
not gonna turn out pretty Knight c6 come
on you could do it can a knight c6 this
is a great spot if I went here there's
rook check and this guy's dead
I gotta stop the rooks from getting
active
man I'm getting crunched crunch time
crunch time maybe I could do that I
think I have to kick that rook away I
need to cook I need to cook the rook
need to kick the rook away my bishop
wants to be able to sit here one day is
that rook getting too excited about
things here what is the big bad plan
here could somebody tell me ah if I go
here there's gonna be some trouble isn't
there so let's not do that oh this is
gonna be a disaster disaster time oh boy
oh I want to cry so bad so bad I want to
cry I gotta go here oh I'm dead in so
many ways look at all the different ways
I'm dead ah I only have one second it
doesn't matter
oh man I'm dead on position and time man
good game let's go back here ah let's
hit that rewind burger I flipped the
button there let's see ah man I need to
I need to do some homework really really
bad
let's see Queen c2 I gotta find
something other than c5 this is not the
first time I've done this
yeah I've done this before and I never
get a good position when I do c5 so and
I'm too lazy to like actually learn
openings ah man okay so what should I do
instead c5 just d5 I could do what I
could go with just d5 right why not just
D five
hmm just d5 Castle d5 first and then
castle this guy never got working my guy
on c8 I can maybe try B 6 as well I'm
offering a lot of suggestions for myself
right now because I got a this is a
wonderful I'm doing nothing this is a
really good set up right here for white
look how simple it is Knights developed
classically and this guy was just a big
idiot the whole game was he not you see
when I was a 1/1 bat what's that line
one bad piece is enough to ruin your
whole game this guy right here was
stupid
fat guy and c8 and there's there's
fireworks going off in the background
can you hear it
fireworks whoa I'm pretty loud there all
right yeah I got it I gotta go back to
the drawing board clearly here oh ok d5
yeah it's already a tough story no
matter no matter what I do here
everything keeps pointing at this guy
just being a fool so I gotta go back
because there's no way I'm better once
it gets to that point so it's like right
here what do I do we're only four five
moves in I'm gonna try d5 next time I
think d5 and Castle after I have to look
into this line sorry I'm not able to
offer any good advice here but yeah I
just don't know this is my weakest point
and it was clearly highlighted right
here in this game and it won't be the
last time it's highlighted either so
alright yeah good a good way to just
crunch me right there I like oh I like
this I like this mover a lot this
doesn't go with the routine like I let's
just get my Bishop out this is good just
pile up on d5 and there's
what can I do very very awkward a3
induces a weakness on b5 I think I'm
maybe needed to do that otherwise I get
kicked around with beef or maybe even c5
drop that pond and it was a way downhill
right here I thought actually I thought
first it was gonna be the rook swinging
over and I could just do that but Knight
here was the best move that was great 95
very good cleans come off and this is
bean looking for tricks and there's no
tricks I was looking to burn time and I
was way behind on time no good all right
good game